[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the talk my
name is dawn Chen I'm a tech lead of MLK
team at Google
I'm here today to talk about ml kit
Google's machine learning SDK for mobile
I would provide overview of what MLK
does and also what's new since its
inception six months ago I also share
some tips and the best practices to
improve performance accuracy reduce size
and few other things in the end I will
talk about what we're working on two
years ago Google CEO sundar Pichai said
we'll move from mobile first to AI first
world their intersection of these two
worlds means machine learning on mobile
in recent years more and more mobile
apps are using machine learning to
produce fascinating user experiences
with smartphones becoming increasingly
powerful and capable more and more
machine learning logic is shifting from
the server running the cloud to the
mobile device in your pocket
Randi own device mention learning has
many advantages its fast does not it'll
send very expensive RPC calls and in
carloon air or latency it also runs
anytime anywhere with and without
network connectivity it also provides
better protection for user privacy since
the data does not have to leave the
device let me take a quick poll here how
many of you traveled from outside
California to attend this dev summit Wow
welcome welcome to a Silicon Valley I
hope you get a chance to visit Conan
Gate Bridge Fisherman's Wharf and also
enjoy some good food at the local
restaurant around the Bay Area talking
about food my biological watch tells me
is time for dinner so where should I eat
well I'll pull out my phone ask Google
assistant
hi Google I'm hungry any good restaurant
around here
Google system uses machine learning to
understand my question and make
recommendation where to go for dinner
around area and location I'm currently
at when I travel to a new place I would
like to take a lot of photos and Google
photos use image recognition to
understand image content you can
classify photos quickly into a thousands
of categories you can also detect
individual faces pads objects text in
the photo and then make them searchable
by keywords or categories later on
mobile device can now run really
increasingly Suffolk's to machine
learning tasks last spring I took my
family to Tuscany in Italy we drove
around those beautiful hilltop towns in
each of the town there are many signs
but I don't speak Italian unfortunately
I wish said I do so how do I know what
this means
here's where the Google Translate came
to rescue Google Translate can perform
multiple machine learning tasks in a
single journey when I pull up my phone
pointing the camera at the sign it will
use optical character recognition to
detect us text in a sign it will also
use national and natural language
processing the transits attacks from one
language into another finally it will
use speech synthesis to convert text
into voice and using speaker tell me
what the sign is in my own language all
these tasks involve machine learning
combined they produce a seamless and a
powerful user experience this all look
great but as a developer how do I build
something like this well it's doable and
not easy machinery offer requires
specialized knowledge and the years of
experience in training and building ML
models the model training a lot of time
requires a large amount of good
high-quality data the mobile device hi
Ron Ellison aside it has very limited
computing power the models running on a
server in the cloud are often too large
or too complex to run directly on a
mobile device you need to spend a lot of
effort to optimize model for the mobile
usage after finally the app is built
Union worried about how do I deploy how
do I maintain ongoing instrumentation of
the models that becomes another headache
to tackle all this power problems we
launched ml kit Google's machine
learning SDK for mobile which helps the
mobile developers build Android and iOS
apps using machine learning technologies
ml cadiz aim at making machine learning
easy for mobile developers just because
you want to use machine learning on
mobile it does not mean you need to
worry about collecting data building
models training model compression
optimization hosting deployment
downloading model all this Haddock ml
kid will take care of this for you we
provide common turnkey models that work
just OtterBox all the models are
optimized for speed accuracy as well as
efficiency for the model for the mobile
device we provide a one consistent API
across both Android and iOS it's very
easy to integrate ml kit with firebase
tools like remote config or a be testing
for commonly needed machine learning
tasks we have base api's that come with
pre-trained google models that work
outer-box currently there are five api's
we are supporting the test recognition
API are supported on both on device and
the cloud the on device API can
recognize Latin characters and the cloud
API supports a wide range of languages
and special characters face detection is
another API we support which can be used
to detect faces in both static image as
well as live
video-streaming now we also launched
counter detection which can help you to
identify different parts of the face and
you can then apply face masks of users
the barcode scanning can be used to
detect post 1-dimensional in the
two-dimensional barcodes as well as a QR
code image labeling API can detect
objects of various entities inside the
photo and for which spore spawn some
device in the cloud the um device API
supports more than 400 labels which
covered most of common things you see in
photos well the cloud API can support
10,000 labels across many categories
finally our landmark API can recognize
well-known places in the photo like
White House our effort our if this
pre-trained model tunafish your need and
you are an experienced developer with
with that knowledge you know how to
build and train models you're more than
welcome to bring your own custom model
we rank us models intensive low light as
you might know tensorflow is an open
source framework for machine learning
and hence the flow light is a
lightweight version of tensorflow
optimized for mobile platforms for
models trained with tensorflow we
provide your tools to convert and
compress into a format compatible with
sensor for light when you're using
custom model you have two options either
bounded inside your app or hosted in the
cloud if you choose the latter option
the host in the cloud does not mean you
need to build your own cloud server ml
kit and firebase or provide a way for
for you for for you we will manage the
model hosting deployment downloading
upgrade as well as the ongoing
experimentations since ml kid was
launched six months ago at Google i/o we
have made several enhancements first
we greatly enhanced our face detection
models which is now eighteen times
faster and a 13 to 24 percent more
accurate we also polished our text
recognition API by making them more
streamlined
consistent across both sound device and
the cloud in addition we launched 133
point face contour detection as shown in
this image you can see now you can use
our face count or detection API it will
identify the contours of various parts
of your face or anyone's face in the
photo and includes the entire face both
eyebrows eyes nose and lips this is
where the real-time asks can put a
customer faces a customer face mask and
futures like a goggle or some funny nose
on the face and make the mask move waist
face in a live video streaming next I'm
going to share some tips and a best
practices for how to use ml kit so I can
build an impressive mobile apps using
own device machine-learning first of all
I will share a couple tips for achieving
best accuracy there are two things you
should make sure one you should take a
very sharp and a well focused image poor
image focus can really hurt the accuracy
second you should ensure the options you
want to detect in the image has
sufficient size for example for face
detection you should have at least 100
by 100 pixels for each face and if you
want a counter detection in their selfie
mode for example then the face should be
200 by 200 pixels for for the text API
for Latin languages each characters be
at least 16 by sitting in in size if you
use our cloud API to detect and
recognize Chinese Japanese and Korean
the each character in those oriental
language should be at least 24 by 24
similarly bar code also have the size
requirement please check out our online
documentation for more details machine
learning and the libraries can be large
which can slow down the app download
there are two ways to reduce the apk
size first you can build your app as a
Android app bundle
by doing that you enable Google Play to
automatically generate apks for specific
screen density CPU architecture as was
the languages then your user only have
to download the apk sand native code
libraries that match their device
configuration another way you can reduce
apk size is if you the machine learning
feature in your app is not a primary
purpose then you could move machine
learning features which require a make
it into a dynamic feature module in that
way you prevent users from unnecessary
downloading ml models which can
sometimes be large we all know machine
learning involves a lot of computation
so the speed becomes really important
here's some tips how you could improve
the performance for especially for
real-time inference on streaming video
you can reduce the image resolution as a
video frame rate to limit amount of
computation it involves to the inference
when the current frame speed process you
should also throttle incoming video
frames to avoid any backup which
increased memory as well slow down the
performance for real-time face detection
you should use face fast mode which
luckily is the default mode oftentime
480 by 360 resolution is sufficient for
face detection for real-time processing
you should also choose between counter
detection versus classification or
landmark detection but not both because
doing both could be expensive and may
not be fit for the real-time device
real-time processing in a slow device
another tip and trick you should even
use is you should wait for detection to
finish before render the face and
counter together you can check out our
online QuickStart sample app on github
for more details to illustrate what I
mean I will do a live demo let's switch
to the demo mode so for the purpose of
demo I'm using a slower Suite hi 3
year-old Nexus 5x phone because using
the latest pixel phone the difference
are not as prominent in the first video
I'm going to show you without any proofs
and we do not do videos throttling we do
not do any Lake drawing to make sure the
contour and the face are together so if
you just call the API without any
performance improvement you can see the
counters are not falling in the face and
there's a big gap between this two
alright so now I'm going to switch to
another version after applying
performance tips in this version it's
using the exact same Nexus 5x phone but
we throttle the video for incoming video
frame when we're still processing the
current frame and also we wait for the
detection of finish before render pose
the face and the counter as you can see
now the contours are following in the
face all the time they match each other
there's no more gap for so let's switch
back to the slides thank you
if you're using our custom auto API how
to include model becomes a something you
should consider there are two ways you
can either bundle the model inside your
app or host it on a cloud if you bundle
your model in your app it's available
immediately it also does not require any
model downloading so it works offline
but the downside is you get a bigger app
because app contains the model it may
slow down the app download also you
cannot change the model without a new
app release on the other hand if you
have some model in the cloud we provide
all the hosting support for you you get
a smaller app size because after itself
does not contain the model which
translate into a faster installation you
also can choose the download model only
if it's needed the model updates can
come over the air into the app without
any new app release you can also use
remote config and a be testing framework
provided by the firebase to do phase
rollout as much control to pilots the
drawback of hosting model on the cloud
is obviously it means connectivity when
there's no connectivity you don't get
that you don't you cannot download the
model also the model will not be
available and here they're downloaded so
a third option is using a hybrid
approach you can pound on the model the
initial version of model in the app so
make it usable right away after
installation now you can receive model
updates over the air from the cloud if
you are using our base API it's provided
in two different forms for the latter of
better terms
I call it thickened SDK and a thin SDK
in Athey SDK the models actually
provided by the Google Play service
which means they are shared across all
apps the apps itself does not have to
contain the model and which will make
your app smaller text recognition and
the barcode scanning api's are provided
through the thing sdk the second type is
called thick SDKs the
are bound on inside SDK each app will
have their own copy of the model which
will increase the app size face
detection and image labeling are
supported through the thickest case to
use this two type of SDK and use verse
API as provide by the ml kit you need to
include the appropriate MLK dependencies
in your app level build up Gradle file
inside the file inside this dependency
section if you want to use the API
support through the thing SDK you should
add the dependency called
firebase - mm - vision an in addition if
you want to use thick sdk you should
still keep this line because auto vision
API entry points are coming from this
thing SDK dependency but you also need
to add additional dependencies for
example if you want to use image
recognition image detection then you
need to add the FIR base ml vision face
model dependency because it's a thick
SDK
similarly for image labeling if used in
that feature they need to add image
label model dependency next I will talk
about a few new areas we are currently
working on a few new MLK features are
either under development or in early
testing phase we expanded beyond vision
starting natural language processing
with smart reply smart applies a feature
which can enable you to produce
meaningful response based on the current
conversation context we are also
planning to go into other areas like
speech at the same time we will continue
to enhance performance and accuracy of
base api's we launched model compression
and conversion service to our alpha
users which helped them to convert and
compress large model into a smaller and
faster versions for mobile usage the
conversion service contains in alpha
uses pruning quantization installation
as well as the transfer learning
to retrain the large models make them
smaller and faster without sacrificing
too much accuracy fish brain is a
community-based app it enables user to
share the photos of their cache and
within their social networks with a
machine learning model it can identify
any fish with just a photo when they
first came to us their model is more
than 480 Meg bytes by using our
conversion and compression service we
are able to trim down the model to ender
one Mac as you can see the not only
maintain same level accuracy that
actually is actually slightly better if
you are interested in trying out our
model compression service please join
our alpha program by sign up today at G
da Co / firebase / sign up no matter you
are new to machine learning or
experienced AI expert I hope you enjoyed
the talk today and they can take home
some tips and I can't wait to see what
you will build with ml kit if you have
any question are we outside in the Asha
and relaunch and we also have office
hour tomorrow thank you very much for
listening
[Music]